[Music]
happy wednesday greets héctor
mejía with the brief informative for today
april 7 if you have not yet been vaccinated and
think you are catching the virus it is
important that you have a
screening test forget the riders stadium
is called  will offer drive-thru
testing today from 8:00
a.m. to 1:00 p.m. No
appointment required
Families with babies are invited to the
Las Vegas diaper drop-off This
event will be from 10:00 a.m. to 1:00 p.m.
afternoon at the martin luther king center
which is located on maguey and
kerry
avenue babys perón and is the
non-profit organization behind this
project will be done over the counter
however if you need to register
information is available on our
page at disney.com  diagonal in Spanish
attention to those drivers who
are distracted by their phones as
several police agencies will be
patrolling to ticket people
who are looking at  your screen behind the
wheel it is against the law to
drive while using an
electronic device
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have warm temperatures with a
sunny sky for today reaching 80
degrees we will see some clouds and we will have
breezes in the rayet but nothing  What to
worry about the temperatures will
remain in the 80s and 70s for the rest of
the week have a nice day I am
Hector Mejía and this was your brief
informative about them I love you in Spanish
[Music]